une info de dunks est tombé je préfère
vous le dire tout de suite
elle est tombée aujourd'hui figurez vous
qu'il y a aujourd'hui et je suis en
mesure de vous le dire à 21h10 sur ces 8
il ya un nouveau record qui est tombé à
vous dire qu'après ça y aura un avant et
un après c'est le nombre de doigts de
casser avec le feront avant les tombes
et non ouais le plus grandes arcades
c'est pas le record c'est surtout qu'à
la fin le front des gars est
complètement fracassé
[Rires]
[Musique]
oufa ban doit intéresser un pic a donc
comme ça qui fait qu'ils nathalie est ce
que vous avez un don à temps j'ai oublié
mon ton vrai que j'arrive à sucer votre
satisfaire donc oui oui oui j'ai
tellement oui c'est vrai qu'à 53 ans
j'arrive à sucer mois on veut bien voir
d'abus quand elle a cessé
c'est vrai bon et bien on peut bien voir
bah oui bah oui tu veux voir ballon
revient sur un monde dont orteils
ah ouais ouais
d
c'est bon ça ben saoud est possible
c'est fort vous avez une expérience des
doigts désynchronisée tout le monde bien
que moi faites comme moi allez-y quoi
cela vous fait c'est même jour deux ans
le déposer au livre des records
on comprend pourquoi vous êtes ici non
mais c'est sûr qu'à nice et des capsules
et des bouteilles voilà avec la première
fois elle nous l'avait déjà montré un
caïd des efforts vous clément c'est quoi
c'est toucher - né avec madame anne or
c'est dégueulasse ajout pas boire non
non je sais pas j'aime pas ça et vous
moi j'ai les doigts tout cas c'est donc
je fais des combats de comme ça marini a
été quand je vois vos dons vous allez
avoir du mal à trouver un travail
ailleurs